Yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought. That's what it is, that's what it is, that's what
it is. The internal structure of the soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from
the subject. Well, though, so let's start there because we're we're this is this episode we're
focusing on Book Two of The Gay Science and it's our first day on it. We're going to do at least two
episodes on it and we're going to try to focus our attention a little bit more on in what way, shape
or form is Book Two of The Gay Science important for thinking the question of of rhetoric, um, and
yeah, I mean, I I thought that so it begins with aphorism 57 and I thought that 57, 58, 59, and 60
are all tightly coordinated with each other and oftentimes sort of counterbalance each other
and have a sense of rhetoric at least in terms of sort of the um, the rhetorical configuration of our
life worlds, um, uh, at the very center of them and then I even think later uh, there's a long sort of
section basically from like 60 to 75 that introduces the question of women into it over or that becomes
the dominant thematic, um, which I think we should is pretty unavoidable. We should attend to it but then
when we come back to um, aphorism 76, it uh, it this feels like um, Nietzsche's political intervention
given this sort of the rhetorical, um, presuppositions he's setting up in in the first um, like what what
four four aphorisms? So this this very first aphorism 57, to the realists, and in in many ways, yeah, this
is I mean this corresponds to his his earlier essay on truth and lying in a non-moral sense where
you know his his major question is where in the world does a um uh concern about
discovering the truth arise in a creature that effectively is only able to survive by
lying and fabricating the world around it, and you know this this kind of reads almost as um
I don't know literary rhetorical phil, like continental philosophy 101, which is that the world is socially
constructed around us and those sort of positivistic thinkers uh, um, are who imagine themselves as
as experiencing the world as it is are only those who have sort of drunk the Kool-Aid, you know, the
most sincerely is that how you would both read that, that first one? I think so. I mean
yeah, like they're kind of I mean to put it in a little bit of Hegelian terminology they're
they're or Nietzsche's terminology they're symptoms of that inescapability of of that social
construction of reality where it to me it's like this is he's diagnosing the reality hunger that's both
endemic to subjectivity and bleeds into scholarship into more like convoluted and complicated ways, um, so for
me it was on it was unavoidable for me not to read this as such an easy like application to my critique
of new materialism etc. right where it's like this all these people are grasping for reality that's a
function of subjectivity that they're not um, themselves articulating in their text they're just
living that symptom essentially. Well so much of this first aphorism too is about the sort of the ethos
of the spirit of that orientation and you know part of what he's bringing out here is this um, this sense
of superiority of sort of like sobriety sober superiority that such a the realist um, walks around
with, and he suggests that this this sobriety is really a a symptom or a sort of leftover of the the
passion of the feeling of the sort of delirious drunkenness of a century past us, you know this
this line here, you still carry around the valuations of things that originate in the passions and loves
of former centuries. Your sobriety still contains a secret and uh, an extricable inextricable drunkenness.
Your love of a reality, for example, oh that is an old ancient love. I mean I always thought like for
for years, you know, and I just remember like back as an undergrad the sort of passion reason
sort of thing that the categories that one would use when like studying literature or whatever
and I always thought those were weird because I always felt like like I'm pretty passionate about
reason, right? Like I you know and so it from the beginning it didn't really make sense to me and
most people that I know who are invested in reason are quite passionate about about their investment in
reason and its importance etc. So from the get-go the dichotomy between the sort of like artistically
creative and the realistic uh, you know hasn't hasn't made much sense and but they're different they're
different things right they're different styles that undoubtedly um, but that's where you know at the
ends it's like we're not nearly as different as you think and perhaps our goodwill to transcend
intoxication is as respectable as your faith that you are altogether incapable of intoxication
you know although you're right if you want to see some real passion tell a realist that they
live in a socially constructed world right exactly, you know, it's like who is the is the we like
me Nietzsche and people like me in that last sentence like so what does that mean in his idiom to
transcend intoxication because I get a little bit confused with some of the terminology
at least the way that I'm reading it there is a to to develop a certain kind of recognition
of once um it's a it's a reflective it's like um you know I this reality is a drunkenness and
there are different drunkennesses and so like that the capacity to transcend at least from that is a
perspective from which one can uh um remove oneself and see at a critical distance this this um that what we
would call sort of the epistemic realm is just the collection of passions drunkennesses dreams
or I think the the answer is the next one the the next uh aphorism is where he answers that and it's
to create different stuff right like so so overcoming intoxication is I mean he's like
he's talking about the appearance the the the value of the appearance of things right what what at
first was appearance becomes in the end almost invariably the essence and is effective as such
how and this is the crucial point like how foolish it would be to suppose that one only needs to point
out this origin and this misty shroud of delusion in order to destroy the world that counts for real
so-called reality in other words it's foolish to believe that pointing out the socially constructed
quality of anything changes anything right that that's not how things work that and the next
sentence is the key one we can destroy only as creators and that's I mean especially this time
in reading through it right that that destruction creation dialectic is familiar to us but usually
not like this usually it is you must destroy in order to create the you know phoenix from the flame
like the ashes will arise from an act of destruction here it's the opposite it's it's it's the opposite it's
that no the way you destroy something is by making something else right like that and that's
the action yeah making it into something else and so I think that the the sense of uh wanting to awaken
from intoxicate or transcend we who want to transcend intoxication uh is the ones who want to
having seen through the intoxicatory like the the drunken quality that makes our reality our reality
make it something else you know not not to make it the true reality not to make it you know but
something else well this second aphorism 58 reads to me as such a good counterbalance to the one prior
to it because if if the if 57 reads as sort of like I don't know hermeneutics of suspicion um uh
101 you know the world is socially constructed then the second one is don't get too um
don't get too invested in the value of sort of realizing that because I mean how many sort of
like it seems like um at least in our field and related fields so much of the goal is to say well
you know language is arbitrary gender is arbitrary all of these sort of identity markers all of these
conceptual stuff you know it doesn't have some kind of basis in reality and now the recognition of that
is liberatory or emancipatory in some kind of way and that's you know and you know that Nietzsche calls
that a foolishness as if you know the the way in which um one uh um detoxes from the desire for reality
is to really realize that reality is drunkenness and then take that up as one sobriety like
the lesson of of sort of um the critique of the realist is not to imagine oneself from a the skeptical
the new place of skeptical realism uh it's to put oneself in this creative milieu so there has to be some
there has to be a little bit of modesty attached to the critique of realism then in the sense that
because I mean like like we just noted at the end of the first um stanza he kind of couples uh
the realist and the anti-realist or the realist and the person who aims to transcend realism and it's
because I mean again I kind of fall back to Hegel here and I'm sure Nietzsche wouldn't say this
exactly but even in the attempt to transcend realism you're still caught up in that kind in that tendency
of consciousness so it's it's a different form of the symptom or a different articulation of
the the grasp for reality but nonetheless they're on the same plane well another way of saying that is
that um uh the impulse toward reality is no more or less a creative act than the critique of
the impulse to reality as is the sort of the will toward the production of reality
right one none of them none of them are privileged from that sort of ontological epistemic
perspective like none of none of them are from an ethical perspective from an ethical perspective
absolutely you know like obviously Nietzsche's like look go team make shit different right like well
he is and he isn't but I mean so go to 76
because this is like, I mean, this is the perhaps the most politically affirmative or sort of like
positivistic, um, uh, aphorism I think I've ever read from from Nietzsche. This is called uh the greatest danger
oh this is the exception in the rule stuff at the end yeah yeah had there not always been a majority
had there not always been a majority of men who felt the discipline of their heads, their rationality
their sense of sober realism to be their pride, their obligation, their virtue, and who were embarrassed or
ashamed by all fantasizing and debauchery of thought being the friends of healthy common sense humanity would have
perished long ago the greatest danger that hovered and still hovers over humanity is the outbreak of
madness, that is the outbreak of arbitrariness and feeling seeing and hearing the enjoyment and the lack
of discipline of the head, the joy of human unreason the opposite of the world of the madman is not
truth and certainty but the generality and universal bindingness of a faith in short the non-arbitrary
in judgment a man's greatest labor so far has been to reach agreement about very many things and to lay
down a law of agreement regardless of whether those things are true or false this is the discipline of
the head which has preserved humanity but the counter drives are still so powerful that it is basically
with little confidence that one may speak of the future of humanity the picture of things still moves
and shifts continually and perhaps more and faster from now on than ever before continually the most select
minds bristle at this universal bindingness the explorers of truth above all else continually this
faith as a commonplace belief shared by everyone breeds nausea and a new lust in subtler minds and the
slow tempo for all spiritual processes which this which this faith makes necessary this imitation of the
tortoise that is recognized as the norm here would by itself be sufficient to turn artists and poets into
deserters it is these impatient minds in whom a veritable delight in madness breaks out because
madness has such a cheerful tempo what is needed then are virtuous intellects oh i'll use the most
unambiguous word what is needed is virtuous stupidity what is needed are unwavering beatkeepers of the slow
spirit so that the believers of the great common faith stay longer and go on dancing their dance
it is an exigency of the first order which commands and demands we others are the exception and the danger
we stand internally in need of defense now there is certainly something to be said for the exception
provided it never wants to become the rule like you know as a sort of a corollary to those first
two aphorisms that we were looking at yeah he's yeah he's like go team create shit go team creator so long as
it is a relatively small percentage of the population because that much diversity and diffraction and like I mean it's at the
level of the human population it is it is really dangerous to have too high a percentage of thinkers
like that that you know you need the beat if you're going to have the riff then you need to have to be
underlying it if it was all riffs that the music would completely break apart
yeah the exception the exception the exception is important and he's all about the exception but the
exception is only relevant insofar as it's it has relation to the rule right so it's yeah straight
dialectical like you know uh configuration there it's like the rule must maintain
but yeah is that dialectical though because one isn't superseding or supplanting or moving beyond
one isn't being negated I mean one is I mean there is a an opposition installed there
but the rule becomes a condition through through which the exceptional is created and it sustains itself
by slowly parts of it become the rule and other things become exceptions and parts of it become the rule
but that's simply that's way more organic because one could imagine a sort of a heterogeneous
multiple plural way in which exceptions sort of then get routinized in into the rule without it sort
of um yeah operating operating as a full-on you know like here is the rule and then and it negates the
exception or the here is the exception and negates the rule and then there's a kind of you know
dialectical overcoming does that make sense yeah he definitely wants to maintain the integrity of the
rule itself I mean that's you know is the sort of the norm the the sort of standard tempo of
rationality has to be like that's the condition for him for people to think creatively and to and to think
otherwise and you know sociologically it would be dangerous if everybody thought otherwise because
because there would be no baseline against which otherwise would be otherwise well it seems like
there would just be too much fracture I mean for all of the people who are so concerned about
post-modern fracture and sort of like loss of stability and pin Nietzsche as that person like
he seems to have a similar sort of fear so it's it's not uh when i when i read it this time like
and I get, I get that, and I get what he's going after, but there's a way in which, um
well, let me say it this way, I I feel like those who are, you know, who are bristling at the sort of
normative rationality, they're the conservatives today, right? Like, these are people, I mean really, like
in other words, there's a way in which this is really romanticizing the idea of problematizing
you know, and uh, in the, in the political moment in which we live, I don't feel very romantic about the
problematizing of rationality. That was exactly my response too. I was thinking about conspiracy conspiracy
theorists and anti-vaxxers and like, I mean, what happens when the conservative
slow beat keeping breaks down and the clowns come in? But, but that's partly where
I sort of feel like the the narrative he's providing there is too simplistic, and it's
too simplistic in order to privilege the exception, in order to say that the exception is a great thing
and I understand he's saying the necessity of the rule, but I'm like, I'm not sure there's a rule
right? Like it's I'm not I'm not like the whole thing seems like it might already be such an unbelievably
tangled mess that the idea that there is some sort of metronomic uh reasonableness to things and to
what we call them, well, there might be its own story. I mean, to give just an analog to like the current
political climate, like it it seems like, I mean, I don't know if you guys agree with this, but it seems like
like pre-Trump there was a general faith in the government, in the presidency, even with Obama, even
with Republicans who hated Obama, he still performed the role. It seemed like most people had a sense
that the government had our best interests in mind, and then post, during Trump, post-Trump, right, that
image, that lie, just collapsed and so every every person, every every average guy, has now the is
can access the notion that uh of this like irreducible contingency where anything goes, right? And that's
what like you're saying with the rise of conspiracy theories and the fragmentation of any kind of
general notion of truth. That's the like if we were to put an analog for that paragraph to now it seems like
that's the kind of sociological danger of those exceptions multiplying, right, where everybody thinks they're the
exception now, everybody has their own take on reality, right? And and they feel increasingly justified, and
that I don't know, that kind of that hunger and that accessibility of can of that contingency
could be dangerous. I mean, it seems dangerous to me, like at least in at least in America, seems very
dangerous to me. I mean, like I would go before Trump and turn to the Tea Party, but the Tea Party, you know, as a
relatively marginal group wing faction within the conservatives, increasingly I mean you get with
Sarah Palin, like increasingly becoming mainstream, but it's a yeah it's it's um, and this is where I
mean like John you you're you're concerned with the language of the rule I think is well founded here
because it's not monologic at all, it's certainly not self-consistent, it's certainly not you know like
doesn't transcend anything and I would think much more in sort of like rhizomatic terms of you know
there's not um there's not like a true false decision to be made in terms of the rule or the
consistency question in terms of the rule, but there are um there is a collection of more or less like
deeper ruts of you know of orientations of agreements of you know ways of of configuring and so it's not that
is what like went dialectically from a rule to the gestalt into the into the exception, but it does feel
like that network is increasingly uh um pulling out and there are more and more tangents. It's
increasingly de-territorialized, yeah, yeah, right, increasingly more lines of flight and you know I mean
like I like similar to Deleuze you know I I mean perhaps this this passage makes it sounds more
romantic but you know de-territorialization has a whole lot of value. It's also one of the
quickest routes to death, right? And that's where it's like so because the premise of the thing is
again this is the truth and lies argument which is that like we have forced an agreement about what
we call things, right? We call this hard instead of soft we call this like that's that sort of coercive
agreement and and there is the presumption like in that like that that sort of coercive agreement
you know which was installed violently but that that's established a you know a normative background
against which divergence becomes possible and so you you need the rule in order to to have the
exception in that regard, but I'm like I don't believe we're calling things the same things
I don't believe that we've ever called things the same things like I I'm not sure that there ever was
this sort of hard and soft and you know like I'm not sure that that story
the story about the baseline that gets us the exceptions and the rules is uh um I mean a very
Good story, maybe, or is an adequate story, or is, is, is complex enough
Well, I think we could definitely complicate it because no, I mean, on the one hand I would agree
with you know, I don't think, I mean this would just be a general um critique of identity and equality is
and you know I think Nietzsche would fully be on board with that as even you know it's you know
forget about it's not just that no two leaves are the same and that there's a sort of um elision
of difference in the sort of the conceptualization of things but even across variations of the concept
there is no simple concept of hard or soft that that is sort of accessed every time it is it is um
exercised there is and to bring us back to the question of rhetoric and I think this is in many ways the power
of rhetoric is there is that configuration to to make the equation even at the from one from one
instantiation of a concept to another even though it's never just a single concept no that's that's
right because that's where I think I think words to to me increasingly even sort of precise disciplinary
terms sound a lot more like the word freedom like freedom is one of those words it's just like
like affectively full but contently it could be anything like it could be anything like except
that everyone's in favor of it right like it's it's ubiquitously good and positive but no one has any
kind of sense and I'm I I increasingly feel like every term works like that like it's not like we have
precise technical terms on the one hand that we kind of agree on what mitochondria are and or an
abortion is I mean this is in the way come on like you know um and then on the other hand we've got the
sort of vague ambiguous so it's like the rhetorical goes even further than you know that that there isn't
so maybe an aspect of the rhetorical is the is presenting the illusion that there is some sense
of commonality that is that is the basis of the rule right yeah I think the greatest rhetorical I
think the greatest power of rhetoric is that of the equal sign is that of identity yeah yeah right I
mean as I I identity not recognizing Kaiser Soze and say like the greatest trick the devil ever created
was convincing us he didn't exist I was so sure you were going to go there I don't know why I don't
know why no it just seems that I mean this is just where I find language to be so and not just language
but like to be so thoroughly rhetorical is the the production of the equal sign that the the power the
active force right of the of of any kind of equation of any kind of identity claim you know x is y
x is itself whatever it is that's that's an incredibly that's an incredible power and so
at some level maybe what I'm doing is I'm just doing the social constructionist pointing out thing
again like the the the the hermeneutics of suspicion right like and and I do find myself often getting
into that kind of loop you know of that the first aphorism where it's just like but hold on a second
you know um how can we believe no basement x is x right or one is one or two is two you know what
whatever it is um and and I think that's a problem for me for my thinking like I often do get caught
into the loop of just sort of pointing that thing out and forgetting the whole for me the crucial
part that I forget all of the time and you know I mean I say it all the time it's like make some stuff
make something it's like the creation is the means of of destruction like it's easy to forget that and
just to return to the pointing out of like well hold on a second I'm not sure that we even
buy a baseline reality or a baseline normativity or a baseline you know
but this is where this is where I think those two things become synthesized because I mean
uh forget about the content of like you know there's some kind of baseline content to this or that
term because I I think that's bullshit too but I also don't think it matters that there's a baseline
content to this or that thing like I mean come on you know when has there ever been some kind of
real consensus real baseline normative consensus on even something like gender right like even you
know let's go to 12th century medieval Europe you know at a point where maybe gender norms are the
most reified and I still promise you're going to find an incredible amount of incoherence and and
heterogeneity and so it's not about the supposed content of the thing but I do think there is
why did you pick the 12th century I'm just sort of curious like there's got to be something there's
got to be some reason that you went to that rather than like
I have absolutely no okay okay no idea I think I think maybe you know it's because I was just in
Germany I feel like a lot of shit there was sort of like 12th to 14th century okay I just thought it
was just an interesting you know okay sorry yeah yeah um it's more about the repetition of of the
rhetorical equation of the rhetorical configuration, yeah, and so like at the level of I mean or you know
the at the at the sort of the intensity or the um you know the if if the if the rhetorical um
configuration, it is a differential, right? It is productive. It is making equations between things.
the content isn't the important thing; it's the repetition of that differential. So I mean let's just
say like you want to ask like why is this is to return to the question of what we mean by rhetoric and
what I take to be Nietzsche's fundamentally rhetorical quality. I mean the sentence, and this is reiterating
your point, Nathaniel, the sentence directly after the we can destroy only as creators, right, is but let us
not forget this either. It's enough to create new names and estimations and probabilities in order to
create in the long run new things. Yeah, I mean like yeah create create new names create new and repeat
them and say them enough and you make new things like I don't know how much more rhetorical, right?
like that to me is it doesn't mean it's not magic, right? Like that's the mistaken thing. It's not that
sort of version of like I call it a dragon and therefore it's a dragon, you know, um, but it's not like yeah
that's how you you call things different names and through the sort of through that naming and the
repetition, whether or not it's self-identical, whether or not freedom actually adheres from point to
point, it still generates that affective milieu and you can still get some someone, you know, many people
on your tribe, right? And that repetition and that repetition is both it's kind of like Hegel's thing
with the understanding where he's like this is both the greatest feat of humankind and like the biggest
stopping block, like it's the thing that the repetition of truth where the content doesn't even matter.
Nietzsche says at one point it's like yeah you can switch it you can turn it around as long as you get
that like sedimentation of the truth that's what matters rhetorically and historically, but it also seems
like like that's that's the the the foundation of of human civilization in some sense, but it's also
what impedes our development at a certain level. It's it's what impedes something. It's like it's also a
problem, um, for Nietzsche, I think, um, that is the over reliance on that and the faith in our capacity
to establish truths, the territory, the territorialization, yeah, or the the fascism of the territorialization
right is that this thing it needs to produce identity so it doesn't matter what you know if we're creating
some kind of socius, you know, some kind of like common sense, it doesn't matter what the common sense
is so much as it does that it sort of configures us, you know, in relationship ship to it, so that it
feels like there's an identity there, so it feels like there's a commonality there. Doesn't matter, you
know, there's obviously no actual commonality. It's the it's the coordination, and what I was going to say
is in terms of the um uh that the repetition of the the name and the thing it's that it's not just that
we get used to calling at the thing and it becomes that thing and and this is where the the Deleuze
framework is so helpful for me is that you know you change even a small little upper aspect of that
um uh serial apparatus of the repetition of calling a new thing it allows for other things to get
connected to it, other practices, other habits, whatever it is. So you know you start calling the thing the
dragon and then that now is going to allow for I don't know a mythology of the dragon to sort of attend
to it or a science or an evolution or whatever it is and then you've like all you've done is expose the
thing to other other alliances, other sets of relationships, and so you know it's not it's not
even just like the habit of calling it that thing it's that you've sort of can you've even by just
changing one little element to it you've you've reconfigured the thing enough to allow it to be exposed
to new the new sort of antigens. Yeah, yeah.
I just had a a random non really non sequitur thought about this because, um, oftentimes when we
talk about what we're talking about the sort of repetition of language we think of it sort of
pragmatically, which is like the reason we do this is so that we can fucking communicate, right? Like that
we can uh basically more or less get around in the world, you know, and and sort of be referring to
roughly the same kinds of things and roughly even if they're not exactly right like you know it's
whatever there's a pragmatic sensibility, and it just struck me as we were talking about it
this totally different tone of it might also be in this sense of existential connection to people
right that in fact what we get from this is not so much the a logic of identity in the thing
or even the pragmatic capacities to move them but we get to have community yes we get to we get to have
like we get to share or you i get to become we you know right well I mean this is and I oh is this in
Truth and Lies in a Non-Moral Sense, but, like, I mean, we're fundamentally a hard species, like there's a
reason why excommunication is the worst thing that can happen, right? So it's not that's a different, it's
a really different tone to think of it not so much pragmatically as, yeah, it's not so much the use
value of the term as it is this sort of affective connective value or that the use value of the term
is is is the social, right? The formation of the social, the formation of the social, not just the
effective management of the already social. In other words, it's not logistical ever; it is only ever
creative of this or that kind of social life, right? Which would then bring, I'm sorry, I have to lose on
the brain so much, but now think about sort of like the social as being the, um, the condition of the
conscious and the production of desire machines because how where and you know how how and where
the social is produced is also the production of desire and you know obviously well not obviously maybe but
for me that you know the the Deleuzian, Williamian, uh, um, thinking on desire and rhetorical persuasion
for me are incredibly important as well. So like we're going to think about, you know, a lot of
times here's another return as to what does this have to do with rhetoric things so far we've been
talking about these first few aphorisms and um in The Gay Science as being rhetorical in so far as
there's this um quasi metaphoric power of rhetoric to be able to name something that which it technically
is not and there's this creative apparatus to it as well but then there's the other there's another
aspect of rhetoric that is very sort of commonplace to it that rhetoric is in the matter of persuasion
and so at least for me is oftentimes how to the question is how does that sense of rhetorical
configuration relate to a sense of rhetorical persuasion but if we're thinking about um rhetorical
configuration always as a configuration of life and social life and that is itself the production
of of of desiring machines now you've created the non-instrument you've you've allowed yourself to
see how um non-instrumental non-sort of like manipulative persuasion happens all the time
well yeah there there wouldn't be separate moments there's not there would be separate moments
right yeah the configuration of the social is the configuration of desire is the configuration of
of of of persuasion and so yeah what you might want to call you know rhetorical you know rhetorical
intervention it's not parasitic upon the social or on the the psychological or on the the real it is
the production of the real the social as and and and the desired you are going down the anti anti-odipus
i know my head's right there well i was reading you know what interestingly i was reading um
his Leibnitz book though with a fold uh so i don't know you said that i have not read that
is that readable for someone who doesn't know Leibnitz at all so far it is
um so i don't think either of you were really trying to do this or we're doing it but it seemed like
there was a positive valence to your reconfiguration of of rhetoric to to mean the kind of like uh
whatever like fundamental sociality as opposed to the kind of logistical uh like commonality and i
i guess just because we we did the you know the conference and i tend to write this way and think
this way a little bit more maybe cynically it's just that that capacity is always like teetering on the
edge of destructiveness as well as creativity and empathy and all the stuff right so like not
not not even teetering on it's it's right it's identical with it's always loaded with that
potential and so i i know yeah obviously that's sort of an obvious part of this i just wanted to
i i guess stress that because um because well i mean to give like a a more recent example that
everybody seems to have it it's like a touchstone in rhetoric and like there's always an article
coming out about echo chambers or some bullshit like that where it's like the capacity of human
being to connect to each other also leads to the narrowing of possibility and and it seems at least
today in the today's social media landscape it seems to lend itself almost exclusively to
like a desire to destroy something or like either itself or another group right so like every
everybody's coming together and feeling a sense of community in the in the attempt to destroy another
community i mean this is always had this community is defined by the exclusion of what it's not exactly i mean
this is sort of basic stuff but um yeah i just it's not basic i mean it's it's tribal right like
it is it it is that constant sense of the the formation of the collective is the formation of the
exterior of the collective as well um right that which has to be kept outside but i mean i think your
point though Nate was that like that the sort of the technological capacity to create um these
Effectively powerful intense effective communities is just a little bit heightened so and and way more
fractured too like the number of of um really intense communities yeah um that then because the
outside is so large and so existentially threatening to the sort of the safety that one has articulated has
has configured on the inside, you know, I, I can see that as um producing an inclination, a stronger inclination
toward violence. Well, isn't it just straight like doesn't it? I mean, I don't know how much you guys see
of this on Facebook or Twitter or whatever, but it it just when I see that kind of activity these people
are clearly getting something out of it effectively like they they are feeling a sense of importance, a sense of
self identity, community, so these are all usually you think of those as positive things but the the
discourse itself is organized around hatred, vitriol, destruction of others, and it doesn't seem like any
of these people, thousands and thousands of people, that that do this and find some sort of productive value or
addicted to it, they don't seem to be able to, you know, there's no self-consciousness. It feels like a different
species that's partaking in this kind of behavior, like where I just couldn't even imagine unself-consciously
participating in one of those discourses, you know? I mean, it just feels so foreign to me, and it's strange
that that many people can like succumb to that that that tendency or that desire. Well, look what Christianity
do, they got a lot more people than Joe Rogan or right, he's got a lot, he has a lot, not as much as the Pope.
This is kind of related, but I referred to this in the the talk and tubing in as well. It's like
he mentioned this in the beginning of book one, and you kind of get the sense in the couple aphorisms that
we read is that like the arrogance of humanity in assuming that we know what consciousness is and
that we can direct it. We're self-directed. That's that arrogance and that stupidity essentially is
actually a safeguard, which is to me is a weird little paradox. It's like all the bad shit is also
kind of what has saved us from our own like self-obliteration, which I still don't really like
it's a weird like logic to that, but I just found myself attracted to that sentiment that like our
own stupidity, our own arrogance, um obviously it's led to you know the advancement of human civilization
but it's also impeded our development and that that's a good thing. That's a good thing that we
have this kind of like you know just this stopping block within us or this this tendency, this reification
of the self and others and all that that Nietzsche like because you think of Nietzsche as the anti-identity
guy or at least via Derrida right as the deconstructor of identity but again and again or at least you know
here and there he's like no that that tendency like we we kind of have to hold on to it. That's why it's
really I I agree with you on that, and I was struck a couple of times in reading these sections uh you
just the thing that Nietzsche reminds me of time and again and I forget it time and again is he's a
symptomatologist. He's just like how does this thing work and and it's not like the the thing that looks
like the good guy is going to be the bad guy later on and it's it's a good guy for certain
purposes and not for other purposes and not for I mean it's like that that's the that's the whole
fucking shebang right? Like it's um and it's easy to forget it right? It's easy to be like hey innovation
cool like you know like let's make something new because obviously Nietzsche is has a position
right on on lots of things but I mean I I think that you're spot on about that, and it's such a great
reminder and I I have to kick myself regularly to remind myself of that. Well, and because his
diagnostic is always sort of aimed at the level of life is like you know how does
you know all of these things that we tend to think is happening within life you know for him are just forms
of life? So how does this form of life operate? How does it what what is its power, what how does it
express itself through the domination of other of other forms of life? And then he so frequently
takes the perspective of the species and you know the you know in that that one that we read 75
or you know um in some of the other ones it's like we, I think this is in book one, um
the one on the the need uh on the on the teachers of the significance of life is that you you need the
at the level of the species there needs to be a sort of a belief in some kind of reality or sincerity
or whatever that's that propagates you know the human as a species doesn't mean he wants to live
that life he doesn't that doesn't mean that it's sort of like good and a not violent or whatever
else you know, and he should be the last one to ever say that the good is synonymous with
the non-violent. He takes almost like an evolutionary or an anti-evolutionary perspective. I mean, like
would this is just something I'm thinking of right now, but I don't know if you guys have any thoughts
Does Nietzsche ever comment on Darwin? Like, is there an anti-Darwinism? Oh yeah, here, yeah, yeah, okay.
Maybe I just missed, yeah, yeah, because there's certainly a critique of an evolution with a telos.
With a sort of like a spike as in, you know, there's an advancement that there is a sort of a reason
why this thing happened and allowed us to do something better than them before. There's definitely a much
more, um, you know, I mean, he's certainly an evolutionist, but it's it's definitely a much more, um,
less progressive notion, much more of a meander, like multiple meandering orientation to more
more than that. Darwin's is the thinking of the herd, right? Like Nietzsche's interested in the exception,
primarily. So it's like the exception dies out, yeah, right, Darwinian, I mean, the exception doesn't last,
and so the the whole sort of like the movement of the species towards this or that, it's like that
yeah, you know, the the movement of the species is only interesting insofar as it produces the
occasional extraordinary exceptions, you know, but that means that the herd matters and if the herd kills
itself, that's right, exceptions, that's right, that's right, right, that's right, but I mean just in terms
like the logic of the the thing I said a little bit ago about like our arrogance actually impeding our
development but also enabling it, like that seems inaccessible to, I mean, Darwin. I don't know if he had
a huge philosophical background, but like that doesn't seem like that logic would apply to any kind of
evolutionary track, you know what I mean, where it's like, I don't know much about Darwin, but it seems like
like perfectibility is the telos of like species organization, evolution, and development, right? Like
you kind of weed out the faults uh with the species over thousands and thousands of years and you attain
some sort of, you know, um, not really like, not even, I mean, certainly there are versions of Darwinian
thinking that have taken it that way, but really it's, I mean, when you think about Darwin, Darwin
himself is just like, look, there are geological changes and then species adapt based on those
circumstances, right? Right? Like, and they live or die and then there are other geological changes and
then other adaptations, so so there's no perfection there. There is simply response to an environment,
but which by the way is another thing that Nietzsche doesn't like because it's reactive, it's not creative,
right? It's like other things change and then we either live or die, and it's like what what about the
plastic quality of you know of life, like to make other kinds of things you know
it's like you know of life like to make other kinds of things you know of life like to make other kinds of things
like to make other kinds of things you know of life like to make other kinds of things